pagar la deuda de $ 2.500.
No es así de simple;
no se puede simplemente lanzar dinero a este problema
y creer que desaparecerá.
No funciona así en Afganistán.
Así que les dije que me involucraría,
pero con el fin de hacerlo, lo que tenía que suceder
era que se necesitaba llamar a una segunda jirga,
una jirga de apelaciones.
Y para que eso sucediera,
necesitábamos reunir a los ancianos,
necesitábamos reunir a los líderes tribales,
los líderes religiosos.
El padre de Naghma debía aceptar,
el vecino debía aceptar,
y también su hijo debía estar de acuerdo.
Y pensé, si me voy a involucrar en esto,
entonces ellos también tienen que estar de acuerdo con que yo lo presida.
Así, después de horas de hablar
y localizarlos a ellos,
y cerca de 30 tazas de té,
finalmente acordaron que podíamos sentarnos
en una segundo Jirga, y así lo hicimos.
Lo que fue diferente en la segunda jirga
fue que esta vez pusimos la ley en el centro de ella,
y era muy importante para mí
que todos entendieran que Naghma
tenía derecho a ser protegida.
Y al final de esta jirga,
el juez ordenó
que se anulara la primera decisión,
y que la deuda de US$ 2.500 estaba satisfecha,
y todos firmamos una orden escrita
en la que todos los hombres reconocieron
que lo que hicieron era ilegal,
y que si lo hacían de nuevo, irían a la cárcel.
Lo más...
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Y lo más importante,
el compromiso se terminó
y Naghma quedó libre.
Proteger a Naghma y su derecho a ser libre
nos protege a nosotros.
Ahora, con mi trabajo, hay una cantidad mayor al promedio
de riesgos involucrados.
He estado detenida temporalmente.
He sido acusada de dirigir un burdel,
acusada de ser una espía.
Han lanzado una granada en mi oficina.
Sin embargo, esto no termina.
Me parece que en mi trabajo,
las recompensas son mucho mayores que los riesgos,
y cuanto más riesgos corro,
mis clientes corren riesgos mucho mayores,
porque tienen mucho más que perder
si sus casos no son escuchados,
o peor, si son penalizados por tenerme como su abogada.
Con cada caso que tomo,
me doy cuenta de que por mucho que apoye a mis clientes,
ellos también me apoyan,
y eso es lo que me sostiene.
La ley como punto de apoyo
es crucial en la protección de todos nosotros.
Los periodistas son vitales para asegurarse
de que la información llegue al público.
Con demasiada frecuencia, recibimos información periodística
pero nos olvidamos de cómo se obtuvo esa información.
Esta foto es una foto
de la prensa británica en Afganistán.
Fue tomada hace un par de años por mi amigo David Gill.
Según el Comité para la Protección de los Periodistas,
desde 2010, ha habido miles de periodistas
que han sido amenazados, heridos,
asesinados, detenidos.
Demasiado a menudo, cuando nos llega esta información,
nos olvidamos de a quién afecta
o cómo nos llega esa información.
Lo que muchos periodistas hacen, tanto extranjeros como nacionales,
es muy significativo, especialmente en lugares como Afganistán,
y es importante que nunca lo olvidemos,
ya que lo que están protegiendo
no es solo nuestro derecho a recibir esa información
sino también la libertad de prensa, algo vital
para una sociedad democrática.
Matt Rosenberg es periodista en Afganistán.
Trabaja para el New York Times,
y, desafortunamente, hace unos meses
escribió un artículo que disgustó
a la gente del gobierno.
Como resultado, fue detenido temporalmente
y exiliado ilegalmente del país.
Represento a Matt,
y después de negociar con el gobierno,
logré obtener el reconocimiento legal
de que fue exiliado de forma ilegal,
de que la libertad de prensa sí existe en Afganistán,
y que hay consecuencias si esto no se cumple.
Estoy feliz de decir que
hace unos días,
el gobierno afgano
lo invitó formalmente de nuevo al país
y que se revirtió su orden de exilio.
(Aplausos)
Si censuras a un periodista, entonces se intimida a los demás,
y pronto se silencian las naciones.
Es importante que protejamos a nuestros periodistas
y a la libertad de prensa,
porque eso hace que los gobiernos sean más responsables ante nosotros
y más transparentes.
Proteger a los periodistas y a nuestro derecho
a recibir información, nos protege.
Nuestro mundo está cambiando. Vivimos en un mundo diferente ahora,
y lo que antes eran problemas individuales
ahora son realmente problemas globales de todos nosotros.
Hace dos semanas, Afganistán tuvo su primera
transferencia democrática del poder
y el presidente electo Ashraf Ghani, que es un grande,
me hace sentirme muy optimista,
y tengo la esperanza de que va a hacer en Afganistán
los cambios que se necesitan,
especialmente en el sector legal.
Vivimos en un mundo diferente.
Vivimos en un mundo donde mi hija de ocho años de edad,
solo conoce a un presidente negro.
Hay una gran posibilidad de que nuestra próxima presidente
sea una mujer,
y a medida que crezca, se cuestionará,
¿puede un hombre blanco ser presidente?
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Nuestro mundo está cambiando, y tenemos que cambiar con él,
y lo que antes eran problemas individuales
son problemas de todos nosotros.
Según UNICEF,
actualmente hay más de 280 millones
de niños y niñas que se casan
con menos de 15 años de edad.
280 millones.
Los matrimonios infantiles prolongan el círculo vicioso
de pobreza, mala salud, falta de educación.
A la edad de 12 años, Sahar se casó.
Fue obligada a este matrimonio
y vendida por su hermano.
Cuando llegó a la casa de sus suegros,
la obligaron a prostituirse.
Como rehusó, la torturaron.
La golpearon fuertemente con barras de metal.
Le quemaron el cuerpo.
La ataron en un sótano y casi no le daban comida.
Le arrancaron la uñas con alicates.
Un día,
logró escapar de esta cámara de tortura
a la casa de un vecino,
y cuando llegó allí, en lugar de protegerla,
ellos la arrastraron de vuelta
a la casa de su marido,
y fue torturada aún peor.
Cuando conocí a Sahar, afortunadamente,
Mujeres por Mujeres Afganas
le proporcionó un lugar seguro a donde ir.
Como abogada, trato de ser muy fuerte
con todos mis clientes,
porque eso es muy importante para mí,
pero viéndola a ella,
tan lastimada y débil como estaba,
me fue muy difícil.
Nos llevó semanas realmente averiguar
lo que le había pasado
cuando estaba en esa casa,
pero finalmente comenzó a abrirse conmigo,
y cuando lo hizo,
lo que escuché fue
que ella no sabía cuáles eran sus derechos,
pero sí sabía que tenía un cierto nivel de protección
de su gobierno que le había fallado,
y así pudimos hablar
de sus opciones legales.
Decidimos entonces, llevar este caso
a la Corte Suprema.
Ahora, esto es extremadamente importante,
ya que esta es la primera vez
que una víctima de violencia doméstica en Afganistán
estaba siendo representada por un abogado,
una ley que ha estado en los libros durante años y años,
pero que hasta Sahar, nunca se había utilizado.
Además de eso, también decidimos
demandar por daños civiles,
usando de nuevo una ley que nunca se había utilizado,
pero que la usamos en su caso.
Así que allí estábamos en la Corte Suprema
discutiendo delante de 12 jueces afganos,
yo como una abogada mujer estadounidense,
y Sahar, una joven mujer
que cuando la conocí no podía hablar más que susurrando.
Se puso de pie,
encontró su voz,
y mi chica les dijo que quería justicia,
y la consiguió.
Al final de todo, el tribunal acordó por unanimidad
que su familia política debía ser arrestada por lo que le hicieron,
su puto hermano también debía ser arrestado
por venderla
—(Aplausos)—
y acordaron que ella tenía derecho
a una indemnización civil.
Lo que Sahar nos ha mostrado es que podemos atacar
las malas prácticas existentes mediante el uso de las leyes
en la forma que están destinadas a utilizarse,
y mediante la protección de Sahar,
nos estamos protegiendo a nosotros mismos.
Después de haber trabajado en Afganistán
durante más de seis años,
una gran parte de mi familia y amigos piensan
que lo que hago es algo como esto.
(Risas)
Pero en toda su realidad, lo que hago se ve así.
Todos podemos hacer algo.
No digo que todos deberíamos comprar un boleto de avión e ir a Afganistán,
sino que todos podemos contribuir
a la economía mundial de los derechos humanos.
Podemos crear una cultura de transparencia
y responsabilidad legal,
y hacer que los gobiernos sean más responsables ante nosotros,
como nosotros somos ante ellos.
Hace unos meses, un abogado sudafricano
me visitó en mi oficina
y me dijo: "Quería conocerla.
Quería ver como se ve una persona loca".
Las leyes son nuestras,
y no importa cuál sea tu origen étnico,
nacionalidad, género, raza,
nos pertenecen,
y la lucha por la justicia no es un acto de locura.
Las empresas también tienen que sumarse al programa.
Una inversión de las empresas en derechos humanos
es una ganancia para sus negocios,
y seas un empresario, una organización no gubernamental,
o un ciudadano particular, el estado de derecho nos beneficia a todos.
Y al trabajar juntos con una mentalidad concertada,
a través de la gente, del sector público y privado,
podemos crear una economía mundial de los derechos humanos
y convertimos todos en inversionistas globales en derechos humanos.
Y haciendo esto,
podemos lograr justicia juntos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)